We have a voicemail number, which is two one
nine two David P..
We have heard a number of times recently from
this furious Trump beast who calls in Jimmy
from Philly the egg man, a longtime caller
and viewer and listener who we love.
We love the egg man.
He called in and he is now going directly
at Jimmy from Philly.
Take a listen to this.
Hey, Dave.
This is a message here.
Employee Jimmy from Philly.
That's a joke, by the way.
Jimmy is just a caller.
I wanted to tell him why we take our children
to BLM rally.
We take them because we don't want our children
to grow up to be racist, homophobic asshole
like you.
Right.
So I'm a huge shalom.
A huge, huge shot across the bow there from
the AG Man against Jimmy from Philly.
And we will see if I get ten voicemails from
Jimmy responding to the egg man, four of which
will have a bad reception, six of which will
be way too loud to use.
We'll see if that happens.
When I wake up tomorrow morning on the bonus
show today, we are in the last week.
Almost in the last week, less full week.
I guess maybe we could say of that enhanced
six hundred dollar unemployment benefit related
to coronavirus.
That's going to have a big impact when it
ends.
And we're going to talk about it on today's
bonus show.
We also were seeing police use drones even
to monitor nudity at a Minnesota beach.
And I want to talk about that.
And there's the context of facial recognition
technology and other things that are relevant.
And number three, not the best health news
for Supreme Court Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
We're going to talk about what's going on.
This is putting a renewed focus on the Supreme
Court and what may or may not be.
Supreme Court picks that that Trump would
have in the remainder of this term or in a
possible second term, and how Mitch McConnell
might try to obstruct.
And we're going to see how it all plays out.
But we will have a serious discussion about
it on the bonus show today.
Make sure you get access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at join Pacman dot com.
Also, something extra tonight, 9:00 p.m. Eastern.
I will be doing a live stream on Twitch with
international chess master Eric Rosen, a friend
of the show.
Mike continued training for a big upcoming
tournament where I am looking to represent
the progressive political community very powerfully
in a chess tournament.
I am thinking I actually I'm taking it seriously.
Join my training tonight on Twitch at 9:00
p.m. Eastern.
Twitch dot TV slash David Pakman.
It's all happening.
And remember, if you prefer a one hour long
form audio podcast each day rather than little
cut up clips on YouTube, you can get our daily
audio podcast for free on any of your favorite
podcasting platforms.
A lot of people use I tunes.
Many people prefer Spotify.
We're on Pandora.
Google Play.
Stitcher.
All of the pod being.
What else, Sprecher?
I don't even know all the platforms we're
on.
But you can consume the show daily in that
way.
And as people hopefully in like nine months
get back to safely commuting to work, you'll
be able to take a show with you in that format.
Remember the audio podcast available daily?
I will speak to you in mere moments.
On today's bonus show.